Let's go next to our caller from the nine
five, four area code.
Who's calling today from nine five, four.
Hello.
Yeah, that's true.
Hey David, how are you man?
Uh, although I'm right wing, I have watched
your show for a couple months now and uh,
honestly just want to say, I really appreciate
you being, uh, as genuine as you can and you
know, hopefully not to bias, but, uh, my question
is more on a personal know David.
I'm in college right now and I'd been thinking
of, you know, uh, majoring in political science,
but I'm kind of naive when it comes to the
opportunities that may lead with that.
Uh, any, any information you may give me or,
well, listen here, here's my view.
I think that college basically is primarily
for in a lot of different majors.
It is to learn how to think, learn how to
learn, learn how to exist in, uh, environments
that are different than just with family and
friends and starting to learn, you know, behaving
diplomatically and managing relationships
and these types of things.
And also I wish that maybe things were different,
but so much of what exists in terms of opportunities
is not so much about like the subject matter
that you memorize and learn in college, but
about understanding that this is a world that
depends on relationships and networking and
who, you know.
So for me, you know, if the idea is to major
in political science and get an internship
with an elected official and use that to maybe
become an aid to a polo, you know, the, there's
a sort of a path there.
But for me, mostly political sciences, like,
listen, you could do poly Psi, you could do
philosophy, you could do psychology, you could
do sociology, you could do economics.
Or a lot of these are understanding how to
think and learn.
And a lot of the job opportunities will be
very similar no matter where you get a four
year degree for no matter which s, um, a major
you have for your four year degree and it's
mostly going to come down to, are you good
at building relationships?
Are you a go getter in terms of getting internships
and talking to people?
So it's really like if you're interested in
it, do it, but you really need to think about
what it is you want to be doing when you're,
when you're out of college.
Wow.
What a great answer, David.
I appreciate it.
And uh, I also want to say quickly, I really
enjoyed you having Sam Harris on this show.
I'm a big fan of both of you, but, uh, have
a great day, David.
All right.
Thank you so much.
A very, very polite right-winger and a, that's
a delightful, delightful thing to see.